Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Immer noch.
Und Uta Wagenmann und Susanne Schultz vom Gen-Ethischen Netzwerk. Hallo, hier auch noch mal.
Wir hören noch zu.
Sehr schön. Und jetzt geht es die ganze Zeit um diesen Datensatz, den man aus dem Genom herauslesen kann. Und es klingt halt so, die Kritik ist, diese Daten werden zu viel übernommen. Und man möchte das eigentlich gar nicht. Und es gibt aber auch Leute, die die Genomen freiwillig untersuchen lassen. Es ist nicht ganz dasselbe, wie wenn die Kriminalzeit bei dir zukommt, aber es passt gut genug zum Thema, um mal so jemanden zu befragen. Und so jemand ist in diesem Fall auch der Mensch, der dieses Lied empfohlen hat, das gerade lief, Martin Pittenauer, der jetzt am Telefon ist und sich sein Genomal hat untersuchen lassen. Hallo und guten Abend.
Moin Moin. Ja, also ich muss gleich dazusagen, vorneweg der genetischen Fingerabdruck und den quasi gezwungenermaßen freiwillig abgeben zu müssen, das halte ich für ein perfides Instrument, also da wäre ich jetzt auch nicht Freund davon.
Das ist nachvollziehbar bei dem, was man alles gehört hat. Aber trotzdem spannend ist zu sagen, es gibt doch noch eine andere Anwendung fürs Genom, nämlich man kann das abgeben und dann wird es untersucht. Du hast das machen lassen, du hast dafür Geld bezahlt, ich glaube, das ist auch nicht ganz billig.
Ja, es kostet so 100 Dollar einmalig und dann irgendwie für ein Jahr bist du dann in so einem Subscription Service drin, da gibt es mehrere Firmen, die das mittlerweile machen, in Amerika vor allem, weil die Rechtslage halt ein bisschen einfacher ist. Und an sich hat es mich halt interessiert. Ich habe schon immer so ein Interesse ein bisschen für Humanbiologie. Ich habe auch so ein Nebenfach technisch ein bisschen in die Richtung studiert und habe gesehen, dass es mittlerweile relativ billig so ein bisschen mit dem eigenen Genom Spaß zu haben. Und habe mir dann lange Gedanken gemacht, ob ich das auch machen will. Also einerseits aus datenschutzrechtlichen Gründen, also überhaupt datenschutztechnischen Gründen. Und ich will, dass diese Daten überhaupt erhoben werden. Und vertrauenswürdig ich dann die Akteure finde, die dann meine Daten haben. Und andererseits halt auch aus medizinischen Gesichtspunkten, also gerade wenn man so über Nocebo-Effekte nachdenkt oder so. Nocebo, das ist das Gegenteil von Blatzebo. Also dir wird gesagt, du hast eine höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit, krank zu werden und dann wirst du auch wahrscheinlich erkrankt. Diese Geschichte. Da habe ich mir Gedanken drüber gemacht und irgendwann, habe ich mir gedacht, ja, also ich habe mir das ausreichend Gedanken gemacht und ich will ein bisschen Spaß am Gerät haben und habe dann meine Speichelprobe dahingeschickt.
Und das funktioniert tatsächlich nur mit Speichelprobe und hast dann was zurückbekommen?
Zurückbekommen, bekommt man da erstmal eine E-Mail, so von wegen, wir haben jetzt deine Speichelprobe bekommen und dann dauert es irgendwie drei, vier Wochen und dann bekommt man noch eine Mail und dann sagen die einem so, jetzt haben wir das analysiert und jetzt kannst du dich hier einloggen und kannst mal so deine Daten entweder ganz hoch runterladen und hast dann irgendwie so ein 25 Megabyte Text-File, wo dann eine Million sogenannte SNPs drin sind, die du vergleichen kannst mit Software oder du kannst es dir eben auf der Webseite direkt schon aufbereitet angucken, was für Risiken und was für Phänotypen du so in dir trägst. Charakterzüge eher weniger, deswegen habe ich mich da auch gerade geregiert, aber du kannst halt so lesen, du hast wahrscheinlich braune Augen und du hast wahrscheinlich Blutgruppe A0 und solche Geschichten und du kannst halt auch gucken, wo kommen deine Vorfahren her, welche Haplogruppen hast du so und alles total spannend finde ich.
Aber du hast jetzt auch gerade mit den Krankheiten das erzählt, das stelle ich mir schon gruselig vor. Man sitzt dann irgendwie vorm Rechner und denkt so, okay, mache ich das jetzt auf oder nicht?
Ja, ja genau, also das ist in der Tat erstmal die Überlegung gewesen, will ich das überhaupt wissen, will ich überhaupt diese Analyse machen und dann natürlich nochmal in die Überlegung zu gucken, wie sieht es denn jetzt aus? Ist da wirklich etwas ganz schräg in meinem Genom oder ist das halbwegs okay? Aber das ist dann eine Entscheidung, die muss jeder für sich selber persönlich treffen. Das ist auch so eine Frage der eigenen Freiheit.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich würde jetzt nicht nachfragen, ob und was du da entdeckt hast, aber mich würde schon interessieren, ob du anderen Leuten empfehlen würdest, das auch zu machen, jetzt nachdem du es sozusagen getan hast.
Also ich würde auf jeden Fall nicht empfehlen, das jetzt einfach mal so hopp-a-li-hopp irgendwie mal schnell zu machen. Man sollte sich da gut informieren und am besten hat man auch so ein bisschen Vorwissen, gerade was medizinische Studien angeht und was Wahrscheinlichkeiten bedeuten. Und da steht irgendwie, da ist eine 1, 7-fache Chance, Dingsbums zu bekommen, was es dann konkret bedeutet und welche Statistik dahinter steht. Auf jeden Fall mit dem Thema erst mal beschäftigen und nicht irgendwie mal schnell, schnell kippen, weil es gerade billig ist.
Jetzt hast du ja sozusagen, also ganz am Anfang, bevor das Gespräch angefangen hat, gleich klargestellt, du findest dieses Instrument, was es hier beim Massen-Gent ist, was da verwendet wird, um Leute dazu zu pressen, das aufzumachen, findest du nicht gut. Du hast dich aber entschieden, das zu machen und läufst damit ja auch in Gefahr, dass diese Daten möglicherweise mal von dem Betreiber, wo du bist, irgendwo anders landen. Wie hast du da die Abwägung gemacht?
Die Abwägung ist natürlich, einerseits vertraue ich dieser Firma, das ist natürlich ein bisschen albern auch, weil die Firma kann von irgendjemand gekauft werden und dann sind die Daten da mit dabei. Das Risiko gibt es natürlich. Auf der anderen Seite sind es halt auch andere Daten erstmal. Also es sind nicht diese STRs, sondern es sind FNPs. Das sind natürlich potenziell noch reichere Daten, weil da wirklich nicht genommlich sekreziert wird, sondern gematcht wird auf festgelegte Punkte. Aber es ist eine Abwägung und wie gesagt, das muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden. Ich persönlich glaube, dass ich, ich hinterlasse sowieso überall Spuren, die könnte man auch analysieren. Und dass diese Daten jetzt schon textuell irgendwo vorliegen, ja es ist ein zusätzliches Risiko, aber ich finde es jetzt nicht so super schlimm.
Das hat sozusagen für dich aufgewogen mit dem Interesse, was du an dem Thema einfach hast? Und du hast jetzt, das wollte ich nachfragen, einem von einem Subscription Service erzählt, das heißt du hast ein Abo und schickst irgendwie jeden Monat eine Speichelprobe hin, oder was bedeutet das?
Nee, nee, also jeden Monat, das wäre ein bisschen albern, weil so viel verändert sich ja in der DNA hoffentlich nicht. Ja, ja, aber was halt passiert ist, die Forschung kommt weit und korreliert Gene und Stellen im Genom mit neuen Erkenntnissen und neuen Merkmalen. Und das ist eben dieser Subscription Service, der dir dann sagt, wir haben jetzt hier eine neue Studie gefunden oder selbst gemacht. Und das zeigt uns das Folgendes. Also da kriegt man halt dann so ein Jahr lang Updates quasi, was die Wissenschaft Neues in deinem Genom gefunden hat.
Und weil du gerade dran bist, noch eine letzte Frage von mir, und dann hat Uta auch noch eine. Würdest du, wenn so ein Massengednis auf dich zukommt, da mitmachen oder würdest du dich auch dagegen wehren?
Nein, ich würde mich da wehren, bis auf die letzte Haut. Also es mag jetzt absurd klingen, aber da ist mir meine persönliche informationale Selbstbestimmung wichtig. Und dass ich das für mich persönlich mache, ist eine Sache. Und dass ich zu etwas gezwungen werden soll, auch wenn man nicht sagt, es ist freiwillig, obwohl es nicht freiwillig ist, dann ist das was anderes und dann werde ich auch niemandem genommen mehr geben.
Alles klar. Uta hatte noch eine Frage an dich.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur wissen, ob du uns verrätst, bei wem du das gemacht hast, bei welcher Firma.
Ja, also das ist 23andMe heißt die Firma. Das ist irgendwie eine kleine Firma, die auch Google investiert hat, insofern auch ganz böse eigentlich. Die machen für mich einen halbwegs seriösen Eindruck. Und das muss dann auch jeder für sich wissen, wen er da beauftragt und wo er das machen lässt.
Also ich kann dazu nur sagen, ich will dich da nicht brenzen. Und das ist natürlich immer die eigene Entscheidung. Aber gerade 23andMe ist tatsächlich auch dabei, sich auf dem Forschungsmarkt so ein bisschen zu platzieren. Und die haben so ein Programm angefangen, dass sie eben auch die Leute fragen, ob sie bereit wären, ihre Daten, also ihre Gen-Daten eben auch für Forschung bereitzustellen. Und das ist dann was, wo du nämlich schon anfängst, keine Kontrolle mehr darüber zu haben.
Naja, solange ich gefragt werde, ob ich will oder nicht, ist das ja okay. Also da würde ich auch mit dem Gedanken spielen, will ich da der Forschung meinen Genom zur Verfügung stellen. Das ist ja dann, passiert ja dann auch nicht mit irgendwie, das ist mein Name und das ist meine Adresse, sondern das ist passiert ja dann auch unter kontrollierten und anonymisierten Zuständen oder pseudonymisierten Zuständen zumindest. Und da muss man dann auch wieder für sich entscheiden. Aber ich denke, da habe ich soweit Vertrauen. Das kann man jetzt naiv finden oder nicht. Aber ich mir geht es damit mit der Entscheidung nach vor gut.
Haben die Anwesenden noch Fragen an den Herren?
Ich zuerst, haha. Und das beunruhigt dich nicht, dass das jetzt eine Firma ist, die diese Daten irgendwo abgelegt hat. Nehmen wir mal an, diese ganzen Web-Applikationen sind sicher, wo ich jetzt auch noch nicht das ungefähr glauben würde. Deswegen habe ich mich auch tatsächlich selber dagegen entschieden, das selber zu machen bei 23andMe. Aber es ist eine Firma in einer Juristikation, die jetzt ein bisschen weit weg ist. Und es wäre nicht das erste Mal, dass irgendeine Ermittlungsbehörde mit einem richterlichen Beschluss zu einer Firma kommt und sagt, gib mal Daten her.
Ja, das kann natürlich passieren.
Dann ist das ja auch, also so richtig freiwillig ist das dann ja für dich auch nicht mehr.
Nee, dann war ich halt dumm. Also das sind auch riesige Risiken gibt es da natürlich zuhauf. Und über die macht man sich auch Gedanken. Umgekehrt, das ist aber dann schon nochmal ein Unterschied, ob man jetzt da irgendwie falsch vertraut hat oder irgendwie unter falschen Annahmen was freiwillig gemacht hat oder ob man dazu gezwungen wird.
Ja stimmt, aber du hast denen zumindest damit die Kosten abgenommen. Das ist schon mal sehr großzügig von dir.
So kann man so sehen, ja.
So, jetzt haben wir, also irgendwie das, was der Martin da gemacht hat, scheint natürlich sehr interessant zu sein. Jetzt haben wir nämlich noch einen Anrufer, einen weiteren, der dazu sich äußern will, aber den ich gerade nicht dran nehmen kann, weil die Telefonanlage mal wieder spinnt. Na ja, Technik und so, liegt bestimmt daran, dass der Chaos Computer Club gerade hier ist. Ja, das kann ja jeder sagen. Martin, vielen Dank auf jeden Fall und viel Spaß mit deinem Genom. Bis denn, tschüss. So, interessant das mal zu hören von jemand, der das sozusagen von jemand anders hat machen lassen. Und Sil, die ja hier ist, hat das ja selbst versucht. Also nicht das, sondern diese andere Art von DNA-Profiling, über die wir die ganze Zeit sprechen, die ja sozusagen ein bisschen gröber ist. Erzähl mal, wie geht denn das? Kann man das tatsächlich zu Hause machen?
Das kann man tatsächlich zu Hause machen. Wir hatten das vorhin auf der Herfahrt schon kurz. Das Uta vermutete, man braucht da abenteuerliche Gerätschaften und ein Studium und dann noch drei Jahre Training in einem Bootcamp. Ist aber nicht so. Also die Gerätschaften, die man dafür braucht, kriegt man für einen, weiß ich nicht, ein Tausender, pessimistisch geschätzt sogar nur. Und wenn man das alles zusammen hat, dann kann man im Internet nachlesen, wie das geht. Und dann probiert man das mal aus und es funktioniert alles nicht. Und irgendwann funktioniert es dann mal. Und ich habe jetzt überhaupt gar keinen Hintergrund in Biologie. Also das kann man tatsächlich mit relativ wenig Hintergrundwissen auch selber ausprobieren. Und da ging es jetzt um STRs. Also ich habe mir einfach aus diesem, also es gibt ja bestimmte Loki, hatten wir ja vorhin festgestellt. Und dafür gibt es auch schon veröffentlichte Primer. Also diese kleinen Stückchen DNA, die man quasi als Angelhaken benutzt, um die Stücke, diese Marker da rauszufischen. Einfach aus dem Internet gesucht, welche man da benutzt, die mal synthetisieren und mir zuschicken lassen. Und das dann mal zu Hause probiert. Und das ging auch. Und dann musste ich mir noch irgendwie ein paar Freunde suchen, weil ich gerne als Vergleich... Ich brauchte halt was, wo ein Y-Chromosom drin ist. Kann ich nicht mitdienen. Also Freunde suchen, Freiwillige, Freiwillige, tatsächlich, ich hab sie. Das war wirklich mein Freiwillige. Ich hab sie nicht hinter der Tür gestanden. Nee, nee, nee, ganz lieb und nett gefragt. Und dann ging das auch. Und das war auch so eine Erwägung. Ich hatte ja kurz erwähnt, dass ich auch überlegt hatte, 23andMe das mal zu machen. Hab mich aber tatsächlich dagegen entschieden, weil mir das alles zu komisch war, dass so eine komische US-Firma meine Daten zu überantworten. Und die andere Überlegung war noch, es dauert wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so furchtbar lange, bis ich das auch selber kann. Dann mach ich es doch lieber selber zu Hause. Da weiß ich wenigstens, was ich hab.
Wie lange würde es noch dauern, bis du den großen Test auch zu Hause machen kannst?
Das kommt drauf an, wie viel ich verpeile, würde ich mal sagen.
Also gehen wir mal von dem unrealistischen Fall der Nullverpeilung aus.
Beim unrealistischen Fall der Nullverpeilung kommt es darauf an, wie viele Snips ich mir tatsächlich angucken will. Ich würde wahrscheinlich erst mal ein paar anfangen. Aber wenn ich mir ein paar rausgesucht habe, geht das wahrscheinlich innerhalb von ein paar Wochen. So mit Rücklauf, was Bestellungen angeht und Warten auf Lieferungen und solche Geschichten.
Aber dieses Zeug, was du da bestellst, das kann man sich einfach so ordern? Oder braucht man spezielle Kontakte, Bedarfsscheine oder Stempel?
Nö, das kann man sich einfach so ordern.
Okay, nicht schlecht. Jetzt wissen wir also, dass man das im Zahlverfahren auch bald zu Hause machen kann. Aber der eigentliche Teil, mit dem wir heute hier angefangen haben, ist ja, dass die offiziellen Behörden dieses DNA-Profiling machen, um damit Leute zu finden. Das heißt, das klingt in der Theorie erst mal so, Alter, wir haben ein DNA-Profil und dann wissen wir ganz genau, wenn wir das DNA-Profil nochmal finden, das sind dieselben Personen. Und das sind aber, haben wir ganz am Anfang gesehen, auch geklärt, eine statistische Wahrscheinlichkeit. Die sind relativ hoch, aber nun ja, da können auch Dinge schiefgehen. Und das sind natürlich immer die spannendsten Teile, die Anekdoten, wo das tatsächlich mal schiefgegangen ist. Wir haben jetzt zur Auswahl das Phantom von Heilbronn oder menschliche Chimären. Womit wollen wir anfangen?
Oder einige Zwillinge. Fangen wir mal ganz einfach mit den einigen Zwillingen an.
Die gibt es ja hier in Berlin.
Ich erzähle die Geschichte gerne, aber es ist eine meiner Lieblingsgeschichten. Das ist ganz kurz. Das kennt auch wahrscheinlich fast jeder. In Berlin gab es vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich, in KDW einen Juwelenraub. Und dann wurden DNA-Spuren am Tatort gefunden. Und es wurden auch relativ schnell zwei Brüder festgenommen, die dann eben zur DNA-Probe auch richterlich gezwungen wurden. Also per richterlicher Anordnung wurde eine DNA-Probe gemacht, ein Profil erstellt und es stellte sich eben heraus, dass beide Brüder, die nämlich eineinige Zwillinge waren, dass die DNA eben vollständig auch übereinstimmte mit der Spurenprobe. Da aber juristisch man nicht einem der beiden das eindeutig zuordnen konnte, sondern beide gleichzeitig sozusagen im Verdacht standen mussten sie beide freigelassen werden. Wir haben sich dann auch noch beim deutschen Rechtsstaat bedankt und sind vorhin abgedampft, wo die Juwelen geblieben sind, weiß auch niemand. Das ist halt ein Fall, der eben natürlich selten ist, aber da ist die Methode dann doch recht bisher recht hilflos.
Hatten die dann irgendwie ein Alibi oder sowas für die Zeit?
Brauchten sie ja nicht, sie haben auch nichts gesagt zu dem Fall. Sie haben einfach geschwiegen und haben die Technik arbeiten lassen für sich.
Aber wie haben sie denn sozusagen, also wenn es sonst keine Verdachtsmomente gab, wie sind die denn überhaupt auf diese beiden Typen gekommen?
Ne, das weiß ich nicht, es gab wahrscheinlich schon Verdachtsmomente. Aber die beiden haben eben geschwiegen einfach, die haben zum Tatergang nichts gesagt, die haben sich einfach nicht geäußert und haben die Technik für sich erarbeitet. Das haben wir wahrscheinlich vorher schon gewusst, woraus hinausläuft.
Alter Schwede!
Daran wird natürlich jetzt auch gearbeitet, also das ist eben auch eine der Forschungsfragen der Forensik, wie kann man eine Eige Zwillinge eindeutig mit einem DNA-Profil...
Na wir halten mal fest, eine Eige Zwillinge sind jetzt erstmal grundsätzlich verdächtig. Also ist doch sozusagen, aus dem, was wir heute schon gelernt haben, folgt das doch eigentlich direkt. Okay, dann möchte ich als nächstes gerne, finde ich nämlich das Spannendste, die menschliche Chimäre. Also Chimären sind, um mal euren Bildungshorizont ein bisschen zu erweitern, das sind Mischwesen aus der Fabelwelt. Also der greift zum Beispiel diese Mischung aus Löwe und Adler, ist zum Beispiel eine Chimäre. Was sind denn jetzt menschliche Chimären?
Wer will?
Ich?
Also menschliche Chimären, genetische Chimären, gibt es wohl auch in der Natur, ist aber echt selten, also dass sowas von sich aus entsteht. Es gibt Menschen, die in unterschiedlichen Körperzellen unterschiedliche Genome haben. Passiert aber tatsächlich relativ oft, wenn jemand eine Knochenmarkstransplantation hatte. Bei Blutkörperchen werden Knochenmark gebildet. Und das heißt, das Blut hat denn das genetische Profil vom Spender. Alle anderen Körperzellen haben das genetische Profil vom Menschen, also vom Empfangenden. Und das heißt, wenn man zwei Proben von diesen Menschen nimmt, Blutprobe und irgendwie Mund-Schleimhautabstrich, werden die sich unterscheiden. Wenn jemand dort Blut hinterlässt und dann in so einem Massen-Gentest ein Mundabstrich gemacht wird, wird man den nicht finden.
Dann kann gleichzeitig noch jemand anders damit belang?
Ja, das wäre ganz schön asozial, aber grundsätzlich ja. Also es wird wahrscheinlich auffallen, wenn zum Beispiel die verdächtigende Frau ist und der Spender ein Mann. Da wird der Labortechniker wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen stutzig werden. Aber sonst?
Also ich blute sozusagen in den Tatort, erwecke damit den Eindruck, da sei jemand gewesen, den könne man auch feststellen, aber bin dann jemand anders. Das ist ja sehr praktisch für gewisse Leute möglicherweise. Dann haben wir noch das Phantom von Halbron. Auch eine sehr schöne Geschichte. Dann ist jetzt quasi Susanne eigentlich dran, oder?
Das haben wahrscheinlich viele gehört. Viele haben das in den Medien mitbekommen. Das war wirklich mal so ein großes Scheitern der DNA-Suchaktion. Da ging es darum, dass grenzüberschreitende in mehreren Ländern Polizeibehörden ermittelt haben und nach einer Frau gesucht haben, weil sie Spuren bei Mordfällen, vielen Mordfällen gefunden haben, immer dasselbe Spurenprofil. Und deswegen miteinander verbunden haben, diese ganzen Mordfälle. Und dann gab es verschiedene Sonderkommissionen jahrelang gesucht nach dieser Frau, dieser Mörderin eben, bis sie eines Tages dann auch als Ermittlungsansatz hatten, zu überlegen, vielleicht gab es auch eine Kontamination. Das heißt, vielleicht kam dieses Profil, was sie da die ganze Zeit analysiert hatten, gar nicht von der Täterin oder dem Täter, sondern eben von jemand, die mit den Techniken zu tun hatte. In diesem Fall war das eine Verpackerin der Wattestäbchen, die alle da eingesetzt wurden, um Proben zu nehmen an den Tatorten. Das war dann sozusagen das Phantom-Volten. Heilbrauen in Wirklichkeit hatten diese ganzen verschiedenen Taten eben nichts miteinander zu tun und wurden nur so zusammengeführt.
Wenn ich richtig informiert war, war es doch auch so, dass diese Kontaminationen auch daher kamen, dass sie Wattestäbchen verwendet haben, die jetzt eigentlich nicht für diesen Zweck gedacht waren. Sie sind quasi einfach in die Drohung gegangen, haben Wattestäbchen gekauft und haben halt nicht spezielle DNA.
Sie hatten halt im Einkauf geguckt, die Sterilen sind ja viel billiger als die DNA-freien. Aber Steril reicht halt nicht.
Ganz DNA-frei kriegt man diese Dinger wohl auch nicht. Soweit ich gehört habe.
Aber wenn es schon DNA-frei gibt, muss man die nicht kaufen, wenn man DNA-Tests macht. Das ist total Quatsch.
Auf jeden Fall ist das ein typisches Beispiel dafür. Je feiner die Methoden werden, je geringere Spuren schon ausreichen, desto größer ist auch die Möglichkeit von Kontinuinationen.
Vorher hast du das, dass man die nicht ganz DNA-frei bekommt?
Habe ich irgendwo gelesen.
Eigentlich geht das schon. Wie macht man was DNA-frei? Behandeln mit Chemikalien. Das braucht man in Laboren auch relativ häufig, dass bestimmte Chemikalien und Substrate DNA-frei sein müssen.
Es gab in der BKA eine Stichprobe-Untersuchung. Die haben noch einige andere Fälle gefunden, wo die Spur-Spur-Treffer auf Kriminalbeamte hingewiesen haben. Polizisten oder Labortechniker. Relativ viele fand ich in dieser komischen. Das hat der Spiegel mal veröffentlicht.
Polizisten, eineilige Zwillinge und Massengentestverweigere.
Ihr seid alle, alle, alle verdächtig.
Jetzt wollen sie deswegen am liebsten die ganzen Labortechniker und Polizisten wiederum in Datenbanken erfassen. Das nennt sich dann Elimination Databanks, um sozusagen dann auszuschließen, dass wenn man diese Spuren findet, dass man die lieber gar nicht weiterverfolgt. Und da weigern sich aber dann in Deutschland zumindest die Polizisten.
Du meinst dieselben Leute, die sich auch weigern, irgendwie eine eindeutige Nummer auf dem Anzug zu tragen?
Genau, so was. Da fällt in plötzlich der gläserne Bürger ein, zumindest der gläserne Polizist.
Sehr, sehr. Aber das ist ja auch geil, wenn es dann so was gäbe, könnte man ein Polizist werden, könnte dann das perfekte Verbrechen. Weil man kann ja nicht am Tatort. Also ich meine, man ist ja dann in dieser Elimination-Datemark. Wäre vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht. So, jetzt wissen wir also, wie man DNA-Profile erstellt, wo die gespeichert werden und auch wie es schief gehen kann. Und was man warum dagegen macht, kennen wir gleich noch. Jetzt gibt es erst einmal das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Heute mal wieder, weil letzter Donnerstag im Oerre das Chaos Radio und zu Gast sind sie ihm zur Folge zum Beispiel jemand aus dem Chaos Computer Club. Das macht ja irgendwie Sinn. Die SIL nämlich. Hallo und guten Abend. Und vom Gen-Ethischen Netzwerk, Susanne Schultz und Uta Wagenmann. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal zum letzten Mal. Wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt der Sendung angekommen, wo es keinen Sinn macht euch nochmal genau zu erklären, was wir schon alles besprochen haben, weil das genauso lange dauern würde, wie die Sendung noch geht. Deswegen, falls ihr gerade einschaltet und euch für DNA-Profiling interessiert, also das, was die Behörden mit euch machen, wenn ihr so eine Speichelprobe abgeben müsst und wo sie das alles speichern und wie sie das machen und warum sie das dürfen und überhaupt empfehle ich euch den Podcast auf fritz.de oder chaosradio.de, der kurz nach der Sendung dann irgendwann immer erscheint. Also wir haben schon geklärt, dass doch ganz kurz gesagt, also wie es geht, wer das macht und wo das Ganze abgespeichert wird. Wir haben auch schon erklärt bekommen, wie das schiefgehen kann, also dass DNA-Profile jetzt irgendwie nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss sind. Und was mich jetzt noch mal interessieren würde, und da hat Sil schon gemeint, das sei alles hochspekulativ, aber natürlich trotzdem spannend, wie man das Ganze hacken kann. Also im Chat meinen sie zum Beispiel, wenn es so eine Elimination-Datenbank gäbe, dann könnte man sehr da sein, DNA-Profil reintun, wäre fortfrei von aller Schuld. Aber dass diese Datenbank noch nicht gibt, geht das noch nicht, aber kann man das sonst irgendwie damit Unsinn anstellen?
Unsinn anstellen? Ja, Unsinn anstellen, dass es sogar akademisch belegt. Ich habe vor zwei Jahren meinen Aufsatz von ein paar israelischen Wissenschaftlern, die einfach nur mal dargelegt haben, was eigentlich allen Forensikern wahrscheinlich klar ist, nämlich dass solche DNA-Spuren an und für sich relativ leicht zu fabrizieren sind. Das sind ja einfach nur lange Stückchen von DNA, die eine bestimmte Länge haben müssen. Vorne und hinten das entsprechende Gegenstück zu der Primer-Sequenz dran. Und fertig ist die Probe. Das ist dann nur DNA, die kann man dann sicherlich irgendwo verteilen. Im Idealfall würde man...
Warte mal, nur zum Verständnis also sagen, ich besorge mir von irgendjemand den Code und kann daraus sozusagen dann wieder eine DNA-Sprohbaste nicht irgendwo hinterlege.
Ja, also kannst du zum Beispiel irgendwo, wenn mal wieder unser Innenminister bei einem Bankett ist, das Glas klauen, das hatten wir ja vorhin schon, dass man aus Fingerabdrücken auch im Zweifelsfall so DNA-Proben extrahieren kann, rausfinden, welches Profil das ist und dir dann so kleine Fläschchen mit Innenminister-DNA bestellen in den Küchenschrank.
Wir machen uns eine kleine Innenminister-DNA. Also ok, du hast ja vorhin schon erklärt, also irgendwie, wenn man das selber, dieses Profil erstellen will, das kostet ungefähr 1000, aber man muss sich das Zeug anlesen. Ist das mit genau denselben Hausmitteln dann auch machbar, dass man das fälschen kann?
Na, nee, das ist ein bisschen aufregender. Also da würde man es, wenn man es ganz einfach macht, synthetisieren lassen von so einem Dienstleister. Das ist dann nicht ganz billig, also man zahlt derzeit ungefähr für so 15 Basenpaare, so was wie 8 Euro. Ich schätze mal, man kommt für so einen kompletten, wir hatten gesagt, nicht mehr genetischer Fängeabdruck sagen, sondern ein DNA-Profil, ein komplettes DNA-Profil schätze ich mal so auf 700, 800 Euro.
Aber wenn das dann untersucht wird, können die dann feststellen, dass es eigentlich nur ein DNA-Profil ist?
Ja, das können sie auf jeden Fall feststellen. Also das erste Problem ist, dass DNA außerhalb einer Zelle nicht unbeschränkt stabil ist, also unter UV-Licht zerfällt es halt irgendwann. Man könnte jetzt, jetzt wird spekulativ, diese Stückchen DNA in irgendwelche E coli oder Hefe-Zellkulunien einbringen und dann diese Zellen in den Züchten aufraspeln, kleine Fläschchen füllen. Dann wäre das auch ein bisschen länger stabil, aber so wie es jetzt gemacht wird, wie die Technologie jetzt funktioniert, kann man das nicht feststellen. Das war Teil dieses Aufsatzes, den ich erwähnte, das vorgeschlagen wurde, noch zu gucken, ob die DNA an den richtigen Stellen methyliert ist. Das ist nämlich nicht, wenn sie synthetisch hergestellt ist, sondern nur, wenn sie tatsächlich aus einem menschlichen Körper kommt.
Das ist das Thema doch in der Tat, zumindest theoretisch und hoch spekulativ angreifbar. Weil du gerade auch wieder den Dienst erwähntest, wo man DNA synthetisieren kann, da tauchte die Frage gerade noch auf diese Firmen, wo man das hinschickt, um seine DNA analysieren zu lassen. Prüfen die nach, von wem die kommt? Also stellen die irgendwie sicher, das ist deine eigenes oder kannst du da einfach irgendwas hinschicken?
Und ich wüsste nicht, wie sie es feststellen wollen würden.
Du könntest ja wenigstens den Anschein erwecken. Also über Facebook kannst du eine Ausweiskopie schicken, dann glauben die, dass du leer bist, der du überhaupt bist zu sein. Also das wird also nicht gemacht, ich schicke deine Speichelprobe hin und die wird dann analysiert.
Ja, das hätten wir vorhin mal den Menschen fragen können, der hier so eine 23andMe-Geschichte gemacht hat, aber ich glaube, die machen das nicht.
Alright, so, jetzt kommen wir zu dem Punkt, wo die Leute vom genetischen Netzwerk, nämlich Uta und Susanne, die die ganze Zeit hier schon erklärt haben, was das geht und warum das geht und dass es davon große Datenbanken gibt. Warum sie morgen eine Symbol-Datenbank in einem großen Eimer Spucke versenken wollen. Was genau ist da los?
Ja, also wie wir ja schon anfangs erzählt haben, ist morgen der Stichtag, dass die ganzen europäischen DNA-Datenbanken, die ganzen europäischen Polizeien vernetzt sein sollen. Das heißt, sie sollen sich gegenseitig automatisch abgleichen können. Man soll gegenseitig da abfragen und die Polizeien können sich gegenseitig abfragen. Das ist morgens der offizielle Stichtag. Das ist dann zu Ende. Also, dass es komplett sein soll, die Vernetzung.
Wir haben am Anfang gesagt, dass ihr folgendes DNA-Profil in der Datenbank habt. Das soll dann mehr sein?
Nein, das soll jetzt einfach fertig sein. Alle Polizeien sollen da jetzt vernetzt sein. Das hat aber nicht geklappt, weil das zum Teil in manchen Ländern noch gar keine zentrale DNA-Datenbank gab oder gibt, weil noch technische Probleme da sind. Aber im Prinzip ist morgen der Stichtag offiziell. Prümen soll sozusagen dieser Prozesse abgeschlossen sein. Das soll alles funktionieren. Prümen ist der Vertrag, der war erst zwischen wenigen europäischen Ländern, eben aus deutscher Initiative heraus, und hat es in Prümen, in der Eifel, damals unterzeichnet worden. Und dann hat die EU das sozusagen komplett übernommen, diesen ersten mal freiwilligen Vertrag, also Vertrag zwischen verschiedenen Ländern. Und morgen haben wir den Stichtag einfach ausgewählt, auch wenn das sozusagen ja nur offiziell ist und noch nicht tatsächlich alles funktioniert, aber es wird in den nächsten Jahren funktionieren, um darauf hinzuweisen, dass eben diese DNA-Datenbanken international vernetzt werden und auch überhaupt in ganz vielen Ländern immer mehr DNA-Datenbanken aufgebaut werden und inzwischen auch mit den USA-Datenaustausch geplant ist, DNA-Datenaustausch um eben gegen diese Massen an Datenbanken, die sich in den letzten Jahren entwickeln und explodieren sozusagen in der Zukunft, um dagegen zu protestieren. Und da gehen wir deswegen vor die EU-Kommission morgen an der Pariser Platz, Ecke Wilhelmstraße, 12 Uhr. Seid ihr alle herzlich eingeladen. Heute machen wir eine kleine Kundgebung, in dem wir einen Datenträger, eine Festplatte und genau, wir wollen den Speichel benutzen, wir können darauf spucken, wir können damit machen, was wir wollen, aber wir geben ihn nicht an der Datenbank ab und wir machen keine Speichelproben.
Und dabei sein wird auch Willi Watte, das ist das Maskottchen unserer Kampagne. Willi Watte ist ein Wattestäbchen, das sich politisiert hat, das ist derzeit wirklich das politisch aktivste Wattestäbchen überhaupt, glaube ich, also weltweit würde ich mal behaupten. Willi Watte ist jetzt in den letzten Monaten viel unterwegs gewesen, hat sich wirklich, hat ja den offenen Brief, den wir an die Bundesjustizministerin geschrieben haben, der übrigens auch unterschrieben werden kann, der ist im Netz zu finden unter www.finger-weg-von-meiner-dna.de, da kann der unterschrieben werden und da werden eben verschiedene Forderungen gestellt, unter anderem Gesetzesrevisionen und eben unabhängige Prüfungen dieser ganzen Datenbank beim BKA und eben auch ein Ausstieg aus diesen Abkommen und aus dieser internationalen Vernetzung. Und genau das hat Willi Watte eben wirklich überall auf der ganzen, in der ganzen Stadt zumindest, also er war vorwiegend in Berlin unterwegs, hat da versucht, das unter die Leute zu bringen. Wir waren beim Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten hier in Berlin, der hat sich auch sehr interessiert vor unserer Forderung. Das wird auch auf der nächsten Konferenz der Landesdatenschutzer Thema sein, weil der Alexander Dix das eben da auch zur Sprache bringen will, der sieht da ganz ähnliche Probleme wie wir. Und ja, und Willi Watte hat unter anderem auch mit anderen Watte-Stäbchen zusammen, das waren fast, waren über 14.000, die er da mobilisieren konnte und mit unserer Hilfe dann auch haben wir das, die Nebenstelle des BKA hier in Berlin umzingelt. Das ist zwar nicht ohne Folgen geblieben, die Polizei stand dann auch gleich da und hat uns wegen Verstoßes gegen das Versammlungsgesetz gerügt und die Personalien vor allem aufgenommen, also wie immer Daten gesammelt ohne Ende. Das alles könnt ihr euch aber wirklich auch angucken auf www.fingerwegvonmeinerdna.de. Das ist eine sehr nette Seite, da kann man Filmchen gucken und sich ein bisschen in das Thema auch einlesen. Also, ist sehr vielseitig und wie gesagt morgen Willi am Pariser Platz um 12, da könnt ihr ihn reifhaftig kurz zusammen erleben.
Wer hat sich dazu bereit erklärt, dieses, wahrscheinlich so ein Ganzkörperkostüm zu tragen?
Oh, das machen wir alle gerne.
Willi ist eine, eine wirkliche, das ist eine echte, Okay, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Aber tatsächlich noch mal zurück zu den Datenbanken. Also diese Vernetzung bedeutet genau was? Dass die vollautomatisch alle Daten in der Datenbank drin sind abgleichen oder dass es weiterhin nur sozusagen dieses Treffer austauschen ist?
Was genau? Also es werden, also zum Beispiel zwischen Niederland und Deutschland, als das geplant wurde, es werden alle Daten noch mal miteinander abgeglichen und da passiert dann auch schnell, also automatisch abgeglichen, ich glaube in regelmäßigen Abständen täglich, wöchentlich. Genau. Und dann mitgeguckt, dann gibt es auch öfters sozusagen Treffer, da ist auch ganz normal, dass dann falsche Treffer gibt, weil eben so viele Daten sind, dass immer wieder auch gleiche Profile vorkommen. Das zeigt eben auch schon wieder das Problem und das passiert dann dauernd und ansonsten gibt es diese No-Hit-Hit-Abfrage, die dann eben von den Polizeien untereinander gemacht werden kann. Das ist also eine Verbund-Datenbank, das ist keine zentralisierte EU-Datenbank, sondern eine Verbund-Datenbank der ganzen nationalen DNA-Datenbanken der Polizei.
Jeder hat seine, aber die sind alle online. Seid ihr jetzt generell dagegen, dass dieses Mittel-DNA-Profil zur Ermittlung eingesetzt wird oder seid ihr nur gegen die Datenbanken oder gibt es irgendwo eine Grenze, die ihr zieht?
Ja, wir haben darüber in unserer Forderung diskutiert, wir haben den offenen Brief auch so gestaltet, dass wir sagen, es gibt Mindest-Forderungen und es gibt sozusagen Maximal-Forderungen. Wir meinen, dass so eine zentrale Datenbank, dass die maximal fordern, dass die komplett gelöscht werden muss, weil wir meinen, dass solche Daten in zentral gespeichert in den Händen der Regierung problematische, überwachungsstaatliche Tendenzen fördern und man immer dann, wenn man erst mal so eine Datenbank hat, dann immer die auch ausgeweitet wird und die Tendenz immer ist, von Sicherheitspolitikern letztendlich die gesamte Bevölkerung speichern zu wollen. Weil es auch in manchen Ländern schon als Projekt gibt, also die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate zum Beispiel haben das jetzt schon als Projekt, dass sie die gesamte Bevölkerung DNA-Profile speichern wollen. Wir sagen aber auch, es gibt Mindestforderungen. Im Moment ist es halt so, dass noch nicht mehr die rechtlichen, also schon unheimlich laxen Grundlagen eingehalten werden. Also es gibt Datenschützer, die jetzt herausgefunden, also der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte Baden-Württemberg hat mal eine Stichprobe gemacht. Mehr als Stichprobe werden da gar nicht kontrolliert. Beim LKA, also bei der Datenbank, das sind auch Verbunddatenbanken in Deutschland, LKA, was haben die gespeichert, hat eine Stichprobe gemacht und davon sind 42 Prozent nicht rechtens gespeichert gewesen und mussten gelöscht werden. Und das ist aber so, das findet nur alle paar Jahre statt. Die Datenschützer sind auch noch nicht besonders aktiv dazu, weil es wenig öffentlichen Druck bisher gibt. Das wollen wir auch ändern. Deswegen ist auch der Dix jetzt wirklich auch mal bereit, was zu machen, weil er merkt, da gibt es irgendwie Interesse. Und das ist also die Minimalforderung, dass zumindest die rechtlichen Bedingungen eingehalten werden. Auch, dass gelöscht wird nach zehn Jahren, dass überprüft wird, all das gibt es kaum unabhängige Kontrolle. Die nächste Forderung wäre eine Revision dieser, das, was jetzt erhebliche Straftaten ist. Das ist ja im Grunde diese Wiederholungstaten, dass eben Kleinkriminalität, jede Art von Vergehen schon jetzt inzwischen da auch gespeichert, also ein Anlass für eine Personenprofilerstellung sein kann. Da sagen wir auch, das muss auf jeden Fall zurückgeschraubt werden. Das ist sozusagen der nächste Schritt, mittelfristige Forderung, dass das ja total stark begrenzt wird, wann überhaupt eine DNA-Probe genommen werden darf.
Ich wollte mal kurz sagen, also einerseits geht es darum, dass diese Daten, wenn sie erhoben wurden, langfristig gespeichert werden in den Datenbanken. Andererseits geht es aber jetzt, also indem ich sozusagen zweite Baustelle quasi, es geht auch darum, wann dieses Mittel-DNA-Profilerstellen überhaupt benutzt wird. Warum seid ihr da dagegen, dass es überhaupt benutzt wird?
Unsere Kampagne ist erstmal wirklich gegen die Datenbanken, gegen die Speicherungen. Das ist unser Hauptproblem und dazu arbeiten wir jetzt und wollen das verhindern, wollen möglichst viele Daten gelöscht haben. Wir finden es was anderes, im ganz konkreten Ermittlungsfall, wenn das, was ich bei Mord oder Vergewaltigung, wenn das noch zusätzlich hinzugezogen wird, einfach nur praktisch die Identität nochmal zu klären, das haben wir uns jetzt so nicht zu geäußern, denke ich, das ist auch erstmal nicht das Problem. Wo wir uns allerdings auch skeptisch zu äußern, ist, dass es immer mehr Methoden gibt, die eben aus solchen Phantasy and Me-Projekten und aus verschiedenen riesigen Human-Genom-Forschungsprogrammen kommen, dass man das auch die Kriminalistik immer mehr versucht, bei einzelnen Spuren, die sie da hat, also nicht in der gesamten Datenbank, sondern bei einzelnen Spuren zu gucken, was kann man denn da alles rausfinden, über die Eigenschaften dieser Person. Und da sehen wir auch, dass es ein Problem ist, dass immer mehr versucht wird, nach Herkunft zu unterscheiden, was dann zum Beispiel wieder Migrationskontrolle relevant ist, wenn man sowas macht, zu gucken, aus welchen Regionen kommen Leute, dann will man die Augenfarbe, dann will man irgendwie die Größe, das ist bis jetzt noch alles sehr ungenau, aber wenn man übersetzt solche Erkenntnisse.
Aber das ist doch, ich muss kurz unterbrechen, bei dem was sie beschrieben hat, ist, dass spielt es noch gar keine Rolle, also diese STRs, was sie erklärt hat, da kann man das ja gar nicht draus ablesen.
Das wird bei den Spuren eben zum Teil, jetzt eben ist das eine Grauzone, das ist rechtlich eigentlich nicht erlaubt, also es dürfen keine anderen Merkmale rausgelesen werden.
Okay, das sind direkt Verboten, ist es überall in Europa so oder ist es nur in...
Also in Deutschland ist es so, ich wollte nur sagen, dass es eben durchaus aber Fälle gibt, wo dann in richterlicher Anordnung dieses Verbot doch irgendwie umgeht, weil gegründet mit Ermittlungsnotwendigkeit, weil es irgendwie keinen anderen Anhaltspunkt gibt und dann wird eben durchaus mal geguckt, wie alt ist die Person vielleicht gewesen oder wie ist die Herkunft, obwohl man eben die Tests, die man da an, also das sind ja dann eher eben Snips oder genetische Tests, wenn man die macht, die sind viel zu ungenau, also im Grunde kann man daraus nicht viel lesen und gerade das mit der Herkunft ist extrem, extrem zweifelhaft, ja, also Herkunft aus der DNA ablesen zu wollen, da gibt's viel zu, aber wir wollen es ja jetzt nicht ausweiten. Das bringt vielleicht noch mal kurz das Problem auf den Punkt, dass DNA-Proben deren Besonderheit eben auch ist, dass es biologisches Material ist, das heißt, es ist unendlich weiter zu spinnen, was da noch alles rausgelesen werden könnte, irgendwann mal, wenn es irgendwann mal als notwendig angesehen wird.
Das heißt, so die Begehrlichkeiten der Kriminalistik und verschiedene Zukunftsszenarien kann man sich vorstellen, auch wenn das jetzt noch nicht so funktioniert, wie sie sich das wünschen würden.
Das heißt, selbst wenn das sozusagen ganz sicher verschiedene Merkmale auszulesen wären, würde dir das als Ermittlungsmittel trotzdem nicht gut heißen?
Ja, weil dann kommt es dann als nächstes zur Speicherung, dann will man schon die Eigenschaften von Personen speichern, das sind ja immer so Schritte. Also da wären wir dagegen, dass man überhaupt mit solchen zweifelhaften Methoden arbeitet.
Okay, das finde ich zumindest eine spannende Sache, die ich wahrscheinlich diskussionswürdig finden könnte, wenn jetzt nicht die Sendung gleich vom Ende wäre. Wir haben jetzt noch einmal eine ganz kurze Frage von Gabriel. Hallo, guten Abend, mach's ganz schnell.
Hi, ich habe noch eine Frage zu der gefälschten DNA-Spur. Ihr habt gesagt, die würde man dann irgendwie synthetisieren lassen, die DNA. Wenn ich schon die DNA-Spur habe vom Innenminister, dann kann ich die doch einfach per PCR amplifizieren und dann großflächig verteilen, oder?
Okay, das ist ein schön viel Fachsprechen. Gabi, ich tue dich mal schon wieder raus, damit du sozusagen nicht aus dem Ruder laufst, weil wir nicht mehr viel Zeit haben. Aber die Frage war sozusagen, wenn man DNA hat, dann kann man die dann nicht einfach amplifizieren, also verstärkt kann man DNA verstärken?
Ja, also amplifizieren, das ist eigentlich das, was PCR tut. Da hat er schon recht. Da kann man noch einfach replizieren. Das ist ja eigentlich nur ein Replikator, die PCR-Maschine mit den Enzymen drin. Was ich eigentlich an dieser synthetisierten DNA spannend fand, war, dass man tatsächlich den Schritt gehen kann von einem digitalen Infobit, wenn jetzt auf Wikileaks irgendwann mal die Code des Datenbanks auftaucht, dass es dann relativ einfach ist, da die auszudrucken.
Wenn ich schon die DNA von jemanden habe, dann würde ich sie sozusagen anwachsen lassen, also vermehren? Okay, wenn ich nur den Code habe aus dieser Datenbank, dann kann ich sie aber immerhin synthetisch basteln? Gut, dann haben wir Gabriels Frage auch noch beantwortet. Wie seht ihr denn jetzt realistisch eingeschätzt die Zukunft dieses Unternehmens, dass ihr da einen Start gebracht habt? Malte ihr euch da irgendwas aus?
Naja, im Moment kann man sich eigentlich nur unangenehme Dinge ausmalen, wenn man sich das anguckt, wie die Vernetzung ist europaweit und so weiter. Wir können da sicherlich nur begrenzt gegen Anstinken, aber wir versuchen es weiter und hoffen auch sehr, dass wir da weiter vorankommen. Also man kann da nur kleine Schritte gehen, weil das ist eben leider sehr weit verbreitet, die Annahme, dass diese Datenbanken das Verbrechen aufklären und sonst nichts. Und das tun sie eben leider nur zu einem ganz gering fühlten Teil, wenn überhaupt.
Jetzt ist morgen dieser Aktionstag mit dem großen Spuckeeimer, den ich immer noch ein bisschen eklig finde. Aber gut, für die politische Aktivismus kann man das mal machen. Was ist denn danach der Plan? Also ich meine, die werden ja morgen nicht vor eurem Spuckeeimer umfallen und dann sagen, oh nein, wir werden deine Datenbanken löschen. Okay, mal gucken, aber nur potenziell abgenommen, das passiert nicht. Was passiert dann?
Also wir sammeln weiter ganz eifrig für den offenen Brief auch Unterschriften. Also nochmal www.fingerwegvonmeinerdna.de könnt ihr den mit unterschreiben und werden auch weiter insistieren, dass Frau Leuthäuser-Schnarrenberger sich da irgendwie zu äußert. Sie hat bisher den irgendwie zwar entgegengenommen, aber in ihrer Behörde ist er inzwischen irgendwie anscheinend verloren, der Brief. Und sie hat sich noch nicht justiziert. Also niemand weiß etwas davon, obwohl wir mehrmals den hingeschickt haben und mehrmals nachgefragt haben. Ist ihr anscheinend irgendwie unangenehm, wo sie ja schon mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu tun hat. Und wir wollen auch einfach noch mal klar machen, dass es eben biologische Vorratsdatenspeicherung und genauso problematisch wie die andere Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist. Wir freuen uns auch sehr, dass der Chaos Computer Club zum Beispiel das mit unterzeichnet hat und wir auch deswegen ja in Kontakt jetzt hier miteinander gekommen sind. Ja und wollen einfach weiter Kampagne, Informationen, Diskussionen fördern.
Also ihr habt diesen offenen Brief von Leuten und Institutionen unterschreiben lassen, habt den dort abgegeben oder wie macht das mit so einem offenen Brief? Schickt man den hin oder was?
Ja genau, das haben wir vorher eben auch versucht rauszufinden, haben angerufen, wurden dann eben auch natürlich und wunderbar.
Werte gehen Sie Dienststelle 33A und holen Sie das Kodefond?
Nee, also wir haben dann richtig mehrfach eben mit denen rumtelefoniert, mit verschiedenen Sachbearbeitern am Ministerbüro und hatten dann eigentlich auch den Termin und dann war auch klar, dass wir den da abgeben werden und da mussten wir dann allerdings nicht rein, weil die Polizei, die da war, die wollte nicht, dass wir in das Ministerium reingehen, die hatten Angst vor Willi Watte, der war da schon dabei, wahrscheinlich auch einfach, weil er so groß und umfangreich aussah, könnten ja auch Waffen drunter geschmuggelt werden, keine Ahnung, was sie gedacht haben. Wie auch immer, wir haben den Brief abgegeben, wir haben ihn vorher auch ein paar Mal per E-Mail dahingeschickt, damit die schon wissen, worum es geht und haben dazu noch eine schöne Kunstaktion gemacht. Also Willi hat da eben seine Wattestäbchen mitgebracht und wir haben dann da nochmal den Slogan unserer Kampagne DNA-Sammelwut stoppen, vor das Bundesjustizministerium geschrieben. Also die Wattestäbchen haben diesen Slogan geformt, haben eben gezeigt, dass sie sehr viel schönere Dinge tun können als Speichelsammeln. Und ja, dann haben wir den Brief da abgegeben bei einer Dame, die uns da empfangen hat. Das haben wir auch alles filmisch festgehalten. Und jetzt haben wir uns mal erkundigt, wie es so aussieht, weil drei Monate vergangen sind, seit wir den abgegeben haben und da hieß es dann eben, er sei irgendwie verloren gegangen. Sie wüssten gar nichts davon und das ist ein bisschen, tut mir leid, also ich glaube es nicht so ganz, dass er verloren gegangen ist. Ich nehme an, das passt gerade nicht ins Begriff.
Hey, offizielle Behörden können total super mit Daten umgehen.
Ja, aber wir bleiben da am Ball und ich denke wir werden auch noch genug politischen Druck entfalten, dass wir da endlich mal eine Antwort kriegen, weil die Frau muss sich dazu irgendwie äußern. Sie ist selber ja eigentlich sehr kritisch gegenüber dieser ganzen Vorratsdatenspeicherung Geschichte.
Aber das ist doch was ganz anderes jetzt. Ja, und wir machen auch weitere Informationskampagnen, dass Leute, die unter Umständen damit konfrontiert sind, dass sie mal ihre Streichelprobe abgeben sollen, dass sie wissen, dass sie eine richterliche Anordnung brauchen, dass sie sich verweigern können. Das ist auch immer ganz wichtig, immer wieder zu sagen. Wir haben auch so mit Willi Watte viele Leute getroffen, auf der Straße, die gesagt haben, gerade Jugendliche, mir ist das schon mal passiert, ich sollte das schon mal machen, und es wurde mir angedroht. Und es ist auch gut, dass die Leute das wissen, in Schulen und so weiter, das verbreiten.
Dann jetzt einmal noch die Webseite.
Genau, die Webseite www.fingerwegvonmeinerDNA.de Und ihr könnt auch, wenn ihr eine Geschichte zu erzählen habt, die euch passiert ist im Zusammenhang mit DNA-Speicherung, euch gerne auch ans Genetische Netzwerk selbst wenden. Das ist auch unter www.gen-ethisches-mit-th-netzwerk.de zu erreichen. Findet sich auf der Webseite fingerwegvonmeinerDNA.de Und da ist es ganz einfach uns zu kontaktieren. Und dann könnt ihr, wenn ihr eine Geschichte loswerden wollt, wir sammeln nämlich auch gerade Geschichten, die Leuten passiert sind im Zusammenhang mit DNA-Speicherung.
Uta Wagenmann und Susanne Schultz vom Gen-Ethischen Netzwerk. Oh Gott, beim letzten Mal verschwinden. Toll!
Das ist ein 80er-Jahrenname.
Okay, Chaos Radio ist ja eh gleich vorbei. Sill vom Chaos Computer Club auch hier gewesen. Was wird dein nächstes Projekt? Wessen DNA wirst du fälschen?
Würde ich niemals tun, es war das hochspekulative und rein empathetisch.
Dann vielen Dank euch allen drei. Und ihr könntet heute ganz ausführlich lernen, wie man das mit dem DNA-Profiling macht und wo und überhaupt. Morgen gibt es, wie gesagt, Spucke einmal vor der EU-Kommission in Berlin. Viel Spaß dabei.
12 Uhr.
Mir bleibt nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst doch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Back-ups.